oh it was a perfect evening princess
stéphanie was there as with posh and
Becks you know international
sophisticate magazine gave us five
gwyneth it isn't actually any place or a
thing in the universe can be up to 104
percent perfect that's how you got
Beyonce oh but we've been through a lot
as well
you I haven't been this upset since my
good friend Taylor was rudely upstaged
by my other friend Kanye he was
defending my best friend Beyonce now you
spent a lot of time with Allender why do
you think that is people have just drawn
to me you know one of my shyest friends
I went to his name to preserve his
privacy but he found my presence so
comforting that he asked me to co-host a
TV show Anderson Cooper 360 Wow anyone
up for a little air icebreakers you know
I once did trust fools of Barry Diller
and it was the beginning of a lifelong
friendship no you need to stand up for
yourself I'm going to tell you the same
thing that I told Mark Zuckerberg right
before he out stood at Waldo Saverin you
are smart you are capable and the time
has come to hit unfriend I also told
mark to lose further just Facebook that
was me I know everyone hates you before
you - no this is good
now that we know we can actually do
something about it and I am an expert of
mediating conflict like when my friends
scary sporty posh and baby had an issue
with my other friend Archbishop Desmond
Tutu for now I will hear your arguments
for why fake Eleanor shells drop should
stay in the good place we can do this
but we must remain emotionless I'm
talking Kristen Stewart on a red carpet
level of emotionless here alright I know
why Jason and I were sent here but why -
honey
oh yeah didn't you really $1,000 is for
charity he would have got 60 billion
actually
but it didn't matter because my
motivations were corrupt I didn't care
about helping the people I raised the
money for I just wanted to prove my
parents wrong stick it to my sister give
fame and attention my only real goal was
just snog around gossiping of the metal
which I did a couple of times actually
oh wait
who else is being tortured are we the
only two I got to assume Jason is as
well.she on you
you know meze on you but his real name
is Jason and he's a dirtbag from Florida
what also tejani is a candidate as far
as I'm concerned yesterday she told me
that she was Taylor Swift's best friend
but Taylor Swift wasn't her best friend
she sucks
believe it or not I actually found
myself in a very similar situation a few
years ago except in that instance
Michael was Javier Bardem and the bad
place was Vanessa redgraves panic room
okay
stop talking do not talk again for a
hundred hours Janet Unni there Janet
when I turned 18 I knelt in front of
princess Grace's dress mausoleum and I
swore to uphold the hostess code I to
Hani al Jamil shall do my level best to
make every event too much do we know
anything about the people like is one of
them an ex-boyfriend or that snooty girl
from Rite Aid who was always silently
judging my purchases it's like yeah
cheeky a Baby Ruth and birth control I
see the irony keep us wiping you don't
know any of the workers okay well then
that's easy I switch tracks kill one
person instead of five but this is hard
cuz they're the trolly I've ever been on
is james franco's ironic trolley it
travels backwards from his penguin
grotto to his garage of adult tricycles
you've never dated anyone like Jason
before I mean of dahle below my station
I once had a brief fling with a non
famous Hemsworth brother but even Larry
Hemsworth had more status than Jason
should have seen this coming
no one can ever truly turn over a new
leaf sure Ben Affleck told me he'd
matured as an artist after he directed
Argo but then right on schedule it was
guess what Donny I'm gonna be Batman
what's his name who the dude the super
depressing religious guy the real
buzzkill whose name I can never remember
Keebler's car Kyra Sedgwick loved her
different fun
not important right now but one time I
think someone isn't lying to me and it
bites me in the ass
I guess Michael really did flip back to
the bad side
Oh does one thing that roast was the
meanest thing I've ever seen and I once
saw a waiter bring Russell throw the
wrong team okay
Michael wants us to stay here for some
reason I don't know we have a train a
conductor at a safe destination I'm
going to tell you the same thing I told
Pippa Middleton right before we went
paragliding in Gibraltar let's go I said
okay now you're all gonna need aliases
cool I'm gonna be Diana Tremaine that
was the name of my fake ID in high
school her address was 1 2 3 whatever
Street Canada City Canada Arizona
bouncers the best character wag such fun
actually it doubled in a bit of acting
after university well the most day I
just stood around while Baz Luhrmann
just threw glitter on me I'm gonna go
take a dump you want me to grab you one
no I'm good thanks sunny little nerd my
damn you're good at this hang out with
Johnny Depp long enough and you become
pretty good at lying like no your whole
thing is an exhausting at all you know I
once shoved a hot dog right down the
throat of the legendary John Wayne she
even named Robson Hill I'm too Hani al
Jamil a vainglorious attention seeker
with enough jealousy to power Elon
Musk's underwater mansion which I've
been to by the way I have actually
remarkable it's remarkable
your honor please no case you frankly
wouldn't believe what we've been through
just to be here today I mean a word
because I just learned everything about
you but keep talking I am like obsessed
with your accent we have made so much
progress and all we ask is an audience
with you to prove it
is that not the very purpose to weigh in
on matters such as ours to paraphrase a
song written by my godfather hey judge
don't make it bad take a sad group and
make us better say aluminum so you saw
your parents in the test yes and I
immediately fell right back into my old
pattern desperately trying to impress
them and earn their admiration then I
heard this little voice in my head
saying to honey don't do this the little
voice in your head sounds like the old
lady from Downton Abbey oh yes sorry
Maggie Smith is my godmother Hey howdy
al Jamil
I'm from international sophisticates
magazine mind if we ask you 582
questions so I was delightful where are
we exactly my pet is hair just off the
coast of barthelona what's one thing
people don't know about you I was such a
tomboy in high school see Wow looking
good ok next question who would you say
is the most famous person in your phone
it's not about who you know
enlightenment it comes from within the
Dalai Lama texted me that keep speaking
of fun I know this super fun drinking
game we can play every time one of you
said something that the other can't
relate to you both drink it could be fun
I once played a drinking game with Ryan
Reynolds and Blake Lively at their
macrobiotic firm with a particularly
robust batch of homemade kombucha do I
have to drink for every word I don't
know up to you just drink Jason okay
they might know afterwards that Jaguars
games alone on my computer at like 3:00
in the morning on Mondays it's so
annoying
have you think here is enough I don't
know how to describe it like a different
zone of time no that sounds stupid a
different clock man I'll watch the game
with you Jason
I enjoy American football I've actually
dated a player once but he wasn't my
type so I set him up with my friend
Gisele Bundchen yeah we got it we always
get it Jason I have an idea but it's a
little risky I need you to act as my
bodyguard like my friend Kevin Costner
in that movie where he was a bodyguard
the bodyguard we're technically supposed
to shut down the bank if anyone from
Florida even walks in look all my life
this money has been a weight around my
neck like the heart of the ocean
necklace my friend James Cameron wants
gave me
[Music]
but if you love someone set them free a
good friend and yoga pupil sting no last
initial told me that I believe in double
trouble why won't you believe in me well
I suppose a little entrepreneurial
spirit never hurt anyone
you know reach for the stars as I said
to my good friend Elon Musk and then he
shot his car in space what a weird creep
why does my friends with him maybe we
should just go there are plenty of other
people I could help but my good friend
Ben Affleck and his crippling addiction
to back tattoos all my other good friend
Matt Damon his crippling addiction to my
friend Ben Affleck welcome to pick up
pet day we have hundreds of beautiful
animals for you to choose from and when
you do make your choice your pet will
bond to your soul forever I haven't had
a pet since Barbra Streisand gave me one
of her cloned Siamese cats and it killed
itself looks like we're inside a diane
von fürstenberg pattern in spring 2013
she'll remember them it's going to
destroy the integrity of the experiment
your honor yes now I have to live next
to a man who once lied and said I wasn't
a Diddy's white party I was there Ellen
I was you must believe me you two won't
be together anymore I haven't met a more
perfect couple since I set a break with
rule a to get the perv
you